the annual nra convention gets underway
in houston today less than 300 miles
from uvalde the city is ramping up
security more than 50 000 nra members
are expected to attend and thousands of
people are expected to protest the event
robert costa is outside the convention
site bob good morning what can we expect
to see there this weekend
good morning despite calls from
activists to cancel this event the nra
is carrying on setting the stage for a
collision as protesters also flock to
the city
the city of houston is on edge ahead of
the nra convention democratic mayor
sylvester turner said the city has to
honor its contract with the nra
no matter how he feels there comes a
point in time when people have to
recognize that it's disrespectful
to be talking about guns
when 19 kids have been killed for the
republican party the moment is a
reckoning with its long-held alliance
with the nra on gun rights several
leading republicans promised to attend
including former president donald trump
and texas senator ted cruz both planned
to speak today governor greg abbott is
no longer attending in person
pre-recording a video message instead
guns are never a responsibility
a gun is a tool despite the mass
shooting in uvalde attendees are
doubling down on their stance on gun
rights it wasn't guns that did it it was
a person we have a problem where people
who are getting mentally ill or not
being they're falling through the cracks
a recent cbs news poll found that among
republicans the majority nearly 75
percent want laws covering the sales of
guns to remain the same or be made less
strict and when it comes to political
influence gun right groups spent 15.8
million on lobbying last year
five times more than what gun control
groups spent but the nra has faced
challenges in recent years following
scandals at its highest ranks
and it's now spending less on political
campaigns
while guns will be allowed into this
event they won't be for trump's speech
due to secret service regulations
michelle
bob an interesting point thank you so
much